auch exotisch auf macs das ist gut ja
genau gibt sie alle rein
die roten sind allein die grünen sind
harmlos alles klar
dankeschön bitteschön gespannt wir haben
das sind die fragen die ihr selber
geschrieben haben
aber natürlich immer in die rolle quasi
eines haters und in der rolle eines fans
du bist seit fast zehn jahren beim
deutschen fernsehen ausrufezeichen
köstlich inzwischen schon zum alten
eisen
logisch wenn sie dich was ist das alte
eisen was es fern was bedeuten zehn
jahre im fernsehen das ist das deutsche
fernsehen gehört nicht zum alten eisen
ich würde nicht mehr sagen dass wir zum
deutschen fans und bürgern also in dem
sinne ist alles in ordnung
letzte frage gewesen
also ist das nicht negativ oder dran
doch schon alles schrott echt ist es ist
alles immer so schnelllebig sein
thomas gottstein erlebe ich ja gut
thomas gottschalk hat sich ewig gehalten
das muss ja jetzt auch in all den jahren
nicht kalt aber ich habe jetzt also ich
glaube weiterhin schrecken hat wenn man
nicht entdeckt
es gibt also du bist chef und moderiert
bei rocket ev du hast nur sein um bei
kika und thomas gamon ist das nicht ein
bisschen übertrieben übertrieben wie
manche übertrieben
ich mache mir ein paar sachen durch ja
doch es ist es übertrieben auf jeden
fall also weniger als mehr und sich auf
einzelne sachen konzentrieren
funktioniert besser aber die umstände
schulden
müssen wir uns auch definitiv weiter
irgendwie und gucken also man soll ja
nicht stehen beim stillstand ist wenn es
was schlimmes gibt dann ist es ein
längerfristiger stillstand also man
sollte sich schnell man soll ab und zu
auch mal kurz durchschnaufen definitiv
man muss auch nicht immer nur das andere
extrem machen nämlich alles mit ihm was
geht aber das geht ja noch
also diese so in ordnung er war sommer
denn sagen du papi schimpfte rein du alt
erwischten vor die andere nächste frage
denkt ihr einfach du blöder [ __ ]
alles klar
ich freue mich wahrscheinlich doch nicht
mehr gebaut du blöder wechsel mit
rockabilly tv machen du und deine
anderen blöden [ __ ] kollegen kanal
auf youtube
vielleicht beim fernsehen keiner mehr
wir versuchen es immer wieder aber
aktuell
wir haben es wirklich versucht und
oftmals ist ist das feedback zu speziell
zu games zu spielen oder der ideen
sondern die ideen die die ideen sind zu
speziell also das ding ist halt etwas
was mich dann auch wirklich krankt das
muss ich dann auch an der stelle sagen
also damals selber so ein bisschen rein
bugsiert ist wir sind zum eigenen
klischee geworden wir sind halt die
dattler die zocker die kellerkinder
nennen nimmt alle klischees und taxi und
verpackt sie schön und schreibt du der
wixxer drauf und gibt es uns ist das ist
alles weg was wir kennen ja ok und das
ist dem präsidenten haut trifft das die
vorurteile gegenüber ja tatsächlich
schon und das ist das ist schade also es
ist so wir haben immer wieder versucht
es gibt viele gespräche ich glaube schon
dass es interessenten gibt aber wenn man
dann ins detail geht also wenn wir eine
tv-sendung auf internet bezogen auf 100
m mit tv qualitäten und mit einem
interaktiven elementen etc vorschlägt
und sendern vorschlägt dann heißt es zu
speziell und dann wenn man dann auch
noch mitbekommt was dann sozusagen ein
pitch gewinnt an dem man teilnimmt
nämlich sex & berger sowie sechs themen
sex exenberger laden oder was im block
keiner nein nicht also das thema sex
wenn leute sex reden ja also das ist
auch in ordnung zieht auch immer aber
wenn du halt so ein aktuelles thema
doch eine menge
verdammt das hätte ich keine ahnung ich
bin auch sehr gespannt ob ob überhaupt
noch fernsehsender uns wollen mich
wollen das weiß man nicht
ich glaube ja es gibt einen minimalen
bedarf aber ich weiß auch gar nicht ob
das wirklich so unbedingt in den
nächsten jahren zu super relevant sein
wird es ist sehr schön es war wirklich
großartig so wundervoll wenn mehr
tv-sender eine ernsthafte eine
ernsthafte brücke schlagen zu dem medium
internet
weil ich glaube sie verstehen immer noch
nicht genau das ist komplett eigenes
ding ist ein komplett eigendynamik hat
und dass man es aber deswegen gerade
deswegen unfassbar gut parallel laufen
lassen kann
ganz viele tolle medienschaffende haben
super wörter wie also pastörs und sport
wie im trance media und transmedia
storytelling und was ich als risiken
gewöhnt aber das sind nur worthülsen und
sie verstehen nicht die die kreativen
freiraum und auch vor allen dingen den
innerlichen freiraum den mann dadurch
generieren könnte da werden wir auch
weiterhin versuchen bei tv-sendern
anzuklopfen und auch mal richtig
besucher anzuklopfen
aber ich glaub auch unter unterstütze
ich sie man das hat er vor zwei jahren
in dem interview gesagt internet wir
haben auf internet wir kommen aus dem
internet und wir wollen im internet
bleiben und wir wollen im internet spaß
haben und bestenfalls auch größer werden
sind alle roten schon eine eigene er
wird noch eine rote software eigene herr
das ist ja das tolle im internet machen
es gibt keine gespräche soll man fängt
an
es ist der gemeinde sind ja mehr rote
drin als grüne oder so mit du feierst du
fertig es erstmal die höhe alles gut so
du blöder [ __ ] wann hast du endlich
erfolg das hatte erfolg was hatte ich je
erfolg ja ebenfalls nicht infrage
ja was ist erfolg ja eine sehr ist so
ich würde sagen danke hatte ich schon
ich hätte gerne wieder mehr man weiß
nicht ist immer so ich mache erfolg
nicht an malibu fest sondern ich mache
erfolg fest an die leute sind happy und
wir haben perspektive und man weiß dass
man
ohne sich stressen zu müssen auch morgen
noch hätte sein kann dass es erfolg
gehört sich super kitschig an ist aber
leider so selten dass man das echt als
ein echter erfolg sehen muss und dann
auch kann und das war schön also den
hätte ich sehr gerne sehr bald bitte
mach ich gespannt
jetzt kommen die ja das ist ja schwierig
also ich bin fragen zu stellen ist viel
schwieriger als die roten nicht du bist
29 immer noch blendend aus woran liegt
das und trauben dankeschön das freut
mich
keine ahnung ich was ich auf jeden fall
sagen kann ich habe auf jeden fall
zugelegt einfach da da sage ich auch
finde ich manchmal ein bisschen blöd
aber es stört mich jetzt nicht anmaßend
so ich würde gerne wieder fitter sein
einfach nur körperlich fitter sein um
besser wende eintreten zu können
aber danke schön
ich mache leider zu wenig um das
äußerliche mir eigentlich egal
ich bin schon eitel keine frage stellen
sich morgens auch gerne von spiegel-
oder richte meine mütze irgendwie
nochmal aus irgendwie im interview aber
die mütze absätze sieht schon wieder
anders aus weiter so die mutter war
nicht so lange geöffnet
die habe ich von einem kommilitonen
geschenkt gekriegt habe ich habe mal
erfolgreich zwei semester studiert
philosophie ist wunderschön die reaktion
sehr vielfältig auf wenn ich das erzähle
woher kommt die bescheidenheit
wahrscheinlich um einen bruder glaube
ich also ich glaube meine bescheidenheit
habe ich oder von meiner erziehung
allgemein irgendwie aber ich glaube
irgendwann bruder ihren der hat mir sehr
viel beigebracht weil ich war glaube ich
ein sehr schlimmes sehr schlimmes kind
ich glaub ich war wirklich nervig ist
kind was [ __ ] ja ich glaube ich war
wirklich ein fixer als kind sehr
hektisches kind auch auf jeden fall und
mein bruder der sieben jahre älter der
hat mir extrem viel beigebracht ich will
nicht sagen alles beigebracht hat mir
einfach sehr viel beigebracht hat mich
auch mal ein keller gesperrt weshalb
einfach mal ein arschloch war so der hat
auch sehr böse sachen gemacht aber ich
in meiner in meiner verklärten
erinnerungen hat er mir beigebracht zu
sagen ey erzählst du mir bitte das maul
und kraft nichts ist selbstverständlich
und man muss auch sachen tun und von
nichts kommt nichts und so waren sofort
meine eltern haben mir dann auch genau
deswegen und ich finde auch echt also
mehr durch die harte schule des älteren
bruders gegangen ja doch auf jeden fall
da gab es noch ganz viele andere
geschichten jugendfrei sind trächtig
werden der zu disney gegen glaub ich
okay aber ich weiß nicht keine ahnung
ich find bescheiden hat es wichtig ich
finde ich finde sich selber größer zu
machen als man ist
hat auch was gutes mache ich auch oft
also mir selber auch mehr selber
nachzugeben
aber das ist immer sofort vorausgedacht
oder so visionär oder so etwas anhalten
so bin ich persönlich manchmal ja
manchmal möchte ich mehr so sein aber
wenn ich nicht ich mag es gerne boden
unter den füßen zu haben weil von da
kann man viel besser abspringen
irgendwie fühlt man sich so als deutsche
gelben legende auch danke schön seltsam
wer ernsthaft seltsam ich habe da immer
wieder auch mal auch mit simon und auch
mit aliens immer wieder zwischendurch
geredet wir machen das wirklich lange
und wir in der frage des selber so sind
wir dann sind wir denn
also legende ist immer ein krasses war
wie advent wenn ihr über die gamescom
ist das für euch
das ist krass das wirklich krass und
gucken nach rechts unten krank und also
frustriert schöne grüße finden falls du
sehen sollte das wirklich krass ich pack
das mal wieder rein
das ist es ist wahnsinnig es ist
wirklich wahnsinnig muss man an anderer
stelle sagen das ist dass es toll und
dann fühlt man sich auf einen seite
fühlt man sich logischerweise geehrt in
ganz netten momenten club man sich dafür
auch gerne mal auf die schulter aber es
ist sehr selten weil man er sich denkt
das müsste man dann auch
viel eher noch zurückgeben also das
feedback was man bekommt oder man müsste
ja mehrmals er daraus machen oder warum
warum kriegen dieser andere leute
weniger feedback als wir so nah also ich
meine wir haben da echt glück gehabt
haben dafür auch viel gemacht und viel
gekämpft auf jeden fall nicht wegen zu
werden darum geht es nicht sondern es
ist ein job zu haben um unser hobby
irgendwie zu frönen und auch gebühren
dazu stehen stellen und was ich wirklich
geil an der ganzen geschichte finde da
machen wir zu wenig draus
bis aber dass man schon und fast wie
viele gute leute kennengelernt hat in
diesem ganzen gaming nordturm sektor und
die allesamt kreativen und wo man
automatisch das gefühl hat die sind auf
einer wellenlänge auch wenn die komplett
anderes viele fahren es gibt inzwischen
mehr tv produktion die sich dem thema
widmen das war auch nicht immer das war
nicht was das war
es ist auch irgendwann gekommen ich sage
nicht dass wir dann bestandteil an
wesentlichen bestandteil daran haben es
freut mich nur sehr dass wir mit am
anfang dabei waren so in deutschland und
jetzt mal von computer zeit abgesehen
und zone also das sind auch die zeichen
der zeit die wir dann irgendwie uns
selber auf die fahne geschrieben haben
ich weiß nicht wie viel man sich man
fühlt sich unter druck das kann ich auch
ehrlich sagen also weil weil weil man
weiß dass man schöne sachen machen
durfte man weiß dass es auch respektiert
wurde
man weiß aber auch dass man alt hat und
man weiß auch dass man immer wieder mit
neuen ideen kommen muss um auch dem toll
zu sein wenn man irgendwann abflacht
oder immer neue ideen bringt aber nichts
konstantes macht dann verschreckt dass
die leute und dann ist das blöd also wir
verspüren glaube ich allesamt auch den
druck dass wir gerne das auch verhalten
würden weil das schon schön ist also
schon schön wenn man weiß irgendjemand
hat etwas gemacht was was auf jeden fall
mal ein begriff ist wenn man games in
deutschland in betracht zieht dass man
nicht bei jedem bei weitem nicht bei
jedem jedem gamer aber dass man schon
beim großteil der gamer
egal ob negativ oder positiv dass man
kritisch schon mal beutelt wurde das
schon ein cooles gefühl und das soll
eigentlich auch gerne so weiter bleiben
fälschungen drücke ich die daumen